نعم يعني الفرق على ارض على الارض واضح في
بعض الولايات بشكل كبير كاضنه وشارلي
اورفا وكلس التي اعلن نائب الرئيس انتهاء
اعمال رفع الانقاض في هاتين الولايتين
ونقصد شارلي اورفا وايضا اقتراب او قرب
فرق الانقاذ من انهاء عملها في ولايات
اضنه وعثمان
وديار بكر في هذه الولايات الثلاثه بحسب
المسؤولين الاتراك قريبا ستنتهي عمليه رفع
الانقاض لكن في ولايات شهدت دمار اكبر من
مما شهدته هذه الولايات الخمسه التي
تحدثنا عنها اي كلس
وشارلي اورفا واضنه وديار بكر وعثمانيه
هناك ولايات شهدت دمار اكبر بكثير كهاتاي
وغازي عنتاب واديمن
وكهرمان مرعش هناك الامور تتطلب وقت اكبر
ضغم كل الدعم المقدم رغم كل فرق الانقاذ
التي ذهبت الى لكن حجم الدمار هناك راويه
كبير جدا ومروع اتحدث فقط يعني عما اعرفه
في
هاتاي وتحديدا في مدينه انطاكيا شوارع
كثيره كنت كنت زرتها من قبل يعني وصلتنا
انباء انها دمرت بالكامل احياء بالكامل
سويت بالارض لم يتبقى الا مبنى او اثنين
وهذه المباني التي بقيت حتى هذه المباني
التي بقيت هي ايله للسقوط ويمكن ان تنهار
في اي لحظه مع اي هزات ارتداديه حتى ان
الهزات الارتداديه لم تتوقف يعني في تلك
المناطق لذلك الوضع هناك كارثه جدا ورغم
كل الامكانيات وكل الفرق التي وصلت الى
هناك لكن اعتقد ان غير كافيه نسبه الى حجم
الدمار الموجود بشكل كبير جدا وما زالت
هناك بعض المواقع وصلتها فرق الانقاذ في
خلال وقت متاخر يعني في اليوم الثالث او
حتى في اليوم الرابع وصلت فرق الانقاذ الى
تلك المواقع وبالتالي هناك لا شك ان تحت
هذه الانقاض هناك عائلات وهناك اشخاص ما
زالوا تحت الانقاض ربما بينهم احياء نتمنى
ان يكون عدد الاحياء كبير وهذا ايضا يرشح
ارتفاع حصيله الضحايا وحصيله المصابين
بشكل كبير خلال الفتره القادمه يعني لغايه
الان التقديرات تتحدث عن 22 الف قتيل من
جراء هذا الزلزال ما بين سوريا وتركيا
وكما ذكرت ربما للاسف يعني هذا الرقم مرشح
الزياده في الساعات القادمه نتمنى طبعا ان
يكون هناك احياء يمكن انتشالهم من تحت
الانقاض زيدان هل هناك اي تقديرات من
مجالس البلديه في المناطق المتضرره حتى من
الدوله تقديرات رسميه على الاقل لعدد
المفقودين بعد ان يعني تم انقاذ بعض او
يعني عدد كبير من تحت الانقاذ هل هناك اي
نوع من انواع التقديرات هل ادلو باي
معلومات عن ربما او تقديرات لعدد
الرازحين تحت الركام لغايه هذه اللحظه
نعم راويه لا يوجد اي تقديرات ولا اي
ارقام رسميه ولا حتى اي توقعات يعني
الموضوع صعب جدا ولا يمكن احصاءه حقيقه
يعني ما نشاهده وما نراها عبر
الوكالات او حتى القنوات التركيه من حجم
دمار لا يمكن لا يمكن حقيقه اي اجراء
احصاء ولو تقريبي او حتى تخمين لعدد
المفقودين لان الكارثه ضربت 10 ولايات في
وقت واحد وفي مساحات جغرافيه واسعه واعداد
المباني المدمره تجاوزت 6400 تجاوزت هذا
الرقم لذلك يعني لا يعلم بالضبط كم هم عدد
الاشخاص الذين كانوا في هذه المباني
وخصوصا ان الزلزال الاول العنيف وقع في
الساعه الرابعه الفجر والجميع كان نيام
بالتالي فرصه من او من استطاع الخروج الى
الشارع والهرب ربما هي فرص كانت قليله
خصوصا في
لذلك لا يمكن التنبا بهذا الموضوع يعني
حاولنا باكثر من مصدر السؤال يعني حتى في
هذا الموقع الذي نراه هو وهو بناء واحد
فقط لا نتحدث عن احياء ولا عن دمار واسع
هذا البناء مكون من 14 طابقا لا لم يستطع
احد التكهن او يعطي رقم تقريبي احد
الاشخاص او احد العاملين بفرق الانقاذ
اخبرنا انهم يتوقعون وهو يعني وهو مجرد
تخمين او توقع وجود 80 شخص يعني هذا
الكلام كان منذ اليوم الاول لكنهم لا
يدركون حقيقه لا يملكون
الاشخاص نعم طيب اذا يعني من خلال السؤال
الجيران والقاتنين في الجوار يعني
استطاعوا تقدير هذا الرقم لكنه رقم ليس
دقيق 100% طيب زيدان يعني نحن نرى في
الصوره طبعا عمليات انقاذ جاريه او يعني
رفع للركام ركام المباني التي تهدمت ونرى
مباني ما زالت صامده هذه المباني التي
نراها الان هل تم اخلائها تحسبا لايها
الذات ارتداديه هل كل المباني الموجوده في
المنطقه يعني
لديها بنيه تحتيه متشابهه ام البعض منها
كان اقوى من غيره
فيعني سقط من او سقطت الابنيه التي يعني
ربما بنيتها تحتيه ليست بهذه القوه بينما
البقيه لا خوف عليهم اما ماذا
نعم الان طلبت من زميلي المصور رصد
المنطقه هنا كما تشاهدين هذا البناء في
الوسط مهدد في الانهيار ايضا هنا على
اليمين ساحاول ساحاول زميلي رصد هذا
المبنى لو سمحت محمد البنائين
بنائين متجاورين او بناءان متجاورين ايضا
فيهما تصدعات وبالتالي تم اخلاؤهم بالكامل
ايضا على يسار الشاشه على اليسار على
اليسار من هنا ايضا هناك بناء متصدع بشكل
كبير كل هذه الابنيه نتحدث عن منطقه واحده
ايضا في الخلف هناك عده ابنيه مشابهه لهذه
الابنيه هذه الابنيه كلها فيها تصدعات
تخشى السلطات التركيه من اي هزات ارتداديه
ربما تؤثر سلبا على هذه الابنيه لذلك تم
اخلاء هذا الموقع بالكامل كل هذه الابنيه
التي شاهدناها الان والابنيه التي في
الخلف تم اخلائها بشكل كامل من السكان وه
شريط وضعته وضعته الشرطه ممنوع الاقتراب
حتى هناك عناصر من الشرطه يكونون قريبين
عندما داخل هذه الابنيه او قريبين من
مداخل هذه الابنيه يمنعون تماما اي شخص من
الاقتراب من هذه المباني خشيه اي هزات
ارتداديه قد تؤدي الى انهيارات جزئيه او
كليه لا قدر الله في هذه المباني او في
غيرها
وهذه المباني
امها ربما اصلاحها هذا شيء ربما يعني
سنسمع عنه في الايام القادمه على كل حال
ايضا زيدان ودات ان اسالك عن من تم
انقاذهم ايضا عن من خرجوا وفقدوا خرجوا
يعني استطاعوا ان ينقذوا حياتهم ولكن
فقدوا منازلهم اين يوضعوا ما هي يعني جهود
الاغاثه التي تقدم لهم اين هم الان ايضا
كيف
يتعامل النظام الصحي التركي هل يستطيع
استيعاب هذا الاعداد الهائله نتحدث عن
عشرات الالاف ايضا من المصابين من جراء
الزلزال
نعم راويه كل الاشخاص الذين خرجوا احياء
اولا يتم اسعافهم الى المشافي القريبه من
هم في حالات حرجه ان لم تستوعب مشافي
الجنوب وتحديدا اضنه ومارسين المجاوره هذه
الاعداد يتم نقلهم جوا مباشره اما
بواسطه الطائرات وزاره الدفاع او واسطات
طائرات تابعه لوزاره الصحه تم نقلهم جوا
الى انقره واسطنبول وولايات اخرى من تبقى
وهم في حاله صحيه جيده وغادروا المشافي او
ممن هربوا من هذه الابنيه التي رصدناها
قبل قليل يتم استيعابهم في مراكز ايواء
مؤقت هي مما تكون مدارس او جامعات او سكن
جامعي او حتى صالات رياضيه